merci
car c'est beaucoup alors mesdames et
messieurs je suis désolé mais morgane
clemenceau n'est pas là je sais que vous
êtes déçu
oh mais c'est une blague
en fait elle se dissimule derrière un
personnage totalement fantasque en
l'occurrence moi miss coquille
merci merci merci merci
[Applaudissements]
alors qui suis-je
je suis la création de morgane clémence
ans je me suis inspiré de son histoire
de ses révoltes de sa personnalité de
son cas
[Musique]
je fais ce que je veux quand je veux où
je veux
si j'ai envie de vous parler avec un
accent espagnol et on parle comme un
espagnol parce qu'il est pour sa filiale
exotiques et cayenne dvd si j'ai envie
de vous faire la danse du ventre
je vous fais la danse du ventre qu'un
groupe de tonnerre d'applaudissements au
corps
arrêtez arrêtez arrêtez arrêtez d'accord
préparation
allez déballage à la merci merci merci
merci
si par exemple j'ai envie de me montrer
mots que je vous [ __ ] mortier ont été
gratuits de ce que vous pensez je m'en
moque des consignes de bienséance de
politesse respecter les critères de
beauté imposée par la société
no mercy changer pour le regard des
autres
[Musique]
tant que ça me fait du bien et que ça ne
vous fait pas de mal non bio fausses
mais bon assez parlé de moi parlons de
grandes comédiennes 20 ans de métier
c'est la première fois qu'elle monte sur
scène en tant que port casque les
morceaux il va falloir aller bon canal
place à morgue avec les morceaux
messieurs dames
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je suis morgan clemenceau j'ai
29 ans et je suis une personne ordinaire
merci j'ai un corps qu'on va dire
quelconque une histoire de ce qu'il ya
de plus commun et cette histoire est
unique comme la vôtre avec miss cookie
c'est différent elle est extraordinaire
elle multiplie par 100 la personne que
je suis mais imaginez si j'étais miss
cookie h24 déjà porté ses talons c'est
une torture par il est aussi pas aux
cavistes cookies non je pense qu'il
n'aurait plus d'amis et deux heures de
préparation faciale donc l'âge non je
n'ai pas le temps non je suis bien je
suis une personne ordinaire
ggd poil gp des factures je pourrais
dire que je paie mes impôts me suis
juste en dessous des fois je tombe
amoureuse
des fois je suis déçu je me pose des
questions
des fois j'ai de la chance il faut j'en
ai pas j'appréhende pour une coloscopie
que je vais faire maintenant tu as fait
normal tout va bien se passer
non je n'ai pas de cancer je vais aux
toilettes comme tout le monde je fais
caca vous fait caca je pense de
montreuil ak oui on hésite tricorps
rebia je pense que françois hollande
fait galetas je pense que johnny dit est
aussi fait caca madonna leonardo
dicaprio marilyn monroe devait faire
quelques uns mais ce coup qui elle ne
fait pas kaka et ça c'est extraordinaire
mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
différence qu'il y as entre l'extra et
l'ordinaire l'art la proposition de voir
la vie autrement
le théâtre a toujours fait partie de ma
vie
il m'a éduqué en complément de
l'éducation de mes parents respirez
prendre conscience de l'espace porter la
voix je pense que vous l'avez compris
regardez son public regardez ses
partenaires quand il y en a ne pas
penser avant ou après mes pensées
pendant sauter dans le vide ne pas
s'excuser d'être là se mettre en danger
rêver concret
rêver concret pierre de gauche pionnier
de la décentralisation et fondateur du
théâtre du jour ne cesse de le répéter
et ces deux mots font partie de ma vie
j'ai 29 ans et j'ai créé une école
burlesque à bordeaux pour que les hommes
et les femmes puissent accepter tels
qu'ils sont et crée des personnages que
moi j'ai pu créer miss cookie se
dépasser devenir son propre artistes
j'ai 25 ans et je commence à faire de
l'effeuillage burlesque démonstration
normalement poussent des cris de joie
ouais voilà on continue on continue
voilà c'est bien encore encore encore le
plus dur est à venir alors bon courage
on y va on y va c'est bon encore en gare
go l'effeuillage burlesque m'a permis
d'exhiber les petits bourrelets sans
aucun complexe
ma petite cellulite et finalement je me
suis rendu compte que ça ne faisait de
mal à personne
au contraire ils s'accrochaient ce que
je racontais il ne reposait pas sur ces
fameux critères de beauté qu'on doit
absolument respecter
non j'ai 20 ans et je pars en chine tout
un spectacle de clowns avec une amie on
ne connaît ni le pays ni la culture ni
la langue on ne connaît personne sur
place nous seuls repères on atterri à
hong kong et on repart de pékin et on a
le goût des autres
très pratique on est arrivés sur place
on a rencontré des gens au hasard des
rencontres on expliquer notre projet
notre projet et on a réussi à jouer huit
fois autant dans des eaux des enfants
des orphelinats des orphelines les
écoles des hôpitaux psychiatriques on a
même fait la une des journaux
notre aventure nous a dépassés j'ai 20
ans non non j'ai pas le temps je
reprends j'ai 17 ans et je décide de
partir tout seul au kenya à la grande
détresse de mes parents mais je me suis
dit je veux absolument réaliser ce rêve
j'ai dévoré les livres de joseph kessel
tous les week-ends je veux passer en
boucle le roi lion je me suis dit un
jour je vais aller là bas je me suis
donné les moyens d'y arriver
j'ai mis de l'argent de côté j'ai essayé
trouver des contacts sur place pour
pouvoir accueillir est chose faite
pendant un mois et demi j'ai travaillé
dans une réserve africaine
j'ai rencontré des artistes locaux ce
rêve est devenu concret j'ai 16 ans et
demi oui ou 17 ans bref j'ai 17 ans et
je passe mon bac et je les ai j'intègre
le théâtre du jour âge sous la direction
de pierre de bouche rythme incessant
malta les cours l'après-midi répétition
le soir en jouant on part en tournée le
matin les cours l'après-midi répétition
le soir présentation ou part en tournée
je mange théâtre je bois théâtre je
pratique théâtre je le donne je me
l'apprivoiser
toutes ces aventures fond la personne
que je suis aujourd'hui je ne regrette
rien je ne regrette rien j'ai fait
certainement des erreurs
en tout cas je suis là devant vous l'art
m'a permis de prendre de la distance
avec la réalité et de mieux affronter la
vie
j'ai 7 ans et je suis terrifiée par le
regard des autres je ne veux pas existé
je ne veux pas qu'on me regarde je ne
veux pas qu'on m'écoute parce que il me
semble que je suis une intéressante que
je suis pas très joli jeu je ne peux pas
être là je ne veux pas qu'on me voie je
veux être en mode fantôme
l'institutrice m'interroge tous les
regards de mes élèves se retourne vers
moi et je me dis qu'est ce que je vois
comment je dois être que pour qu'on
puisse mémé ou qu'est ce que je dois
faire pour je me pose des milliards de
questions
par contre à la maison c'est totalement
différent
je fais le spectacle je crie sur mes
élèves parce qu'ils arrivent en retard
je vends une de mes robes à une
charmante clientes et j'ai accouché de
quatre enfants
voilà avec mon mari jean pierre hanon
toutes ces peurs du passé ont donné la
force de jouer devant plus de ce conte
centaine de personnes et de mettre à nu
devant vous
je suis morgan clemenceau je suis une
personne ordinaire et je vous emmerde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]